heute geht es um Ausbeutung die Guarani
sind ein indigenes Volk und leben in
Paraguay und Brasilien sie nutzen schon
seit Jahrhunderten Stevia zum Süßen von
Tee bei Zeremonien und als Heilpflanze
und was enthält auch Stevia genau die
mittlerweile aussortierte Coca-Cola live
zufälligerweise wächst heute kaum noch
wildes Stevia in Paraguay aber dafür
wird es weltweit verkauft und zwar ohne
dass die Guarani etwas davon abbekommen
wie Unternehmen das schaffen Pflanzen zu
klauen und aus Biodiversität Profit zu
schlagen genau darum geht es heute bei
dr Watson
wenn Großkonzerne von Wissen über
Heilpflanzen oder Lebensmitteln
profitieren ohne die Betroffenen mit
einzubeziehen dann nennt man das
bio-piraterie Bio hat hier nichts mit
ökologischen Landbau zu tun sondern sagt
einfach dass es hier um Lebewesen geht
bei Stevia sieht das so aus japanische
Forscher haben in Exkursionen um 1970
Stevia Samen nach Japan gebracht aber
auch eine halbe Million Pflanzen fast
den gesamten Wildbestand daraus wird ein
Süßstoff extrahiert der seit den 70er
Jahren dort kommerziell genutzt wird aus
heutiger Sicht ist das schon der erste
bio-pirateriefall in der Geschichte von
Stevia aber es geht noch weiter bei der
Zulassung in Europa hakt es nämlich
Coca-Cola treibt gemeinsam mit dem
Mega-Konzern Kargel das
Zulassungsverfahren voran und entwickelt
einen eigenen die wir Süßstoff übrigens
nur eines der vielen Stevia Patente von
Coca-Cola
2011 folgt die Zulassung allerdings
nicht für die Stevia Pflanze selbst
sondern für die stevio Glykoside die
süßenden Stoffe obwohl die aufwendig
extrahiert werden müssen wird der
Süßstoff als besonders natürlich
vermarktet zum Beispiel in der Cola
leicht der Stevia Sprite oder in der
Pepsi next
das hat auch besonders gut funktioniert
denn all diese Produkte gibt es nicht
mehr bei der Extraktion kann nämlich
einen unangenehmer Beigeschmack
entstehen der nicht so gut ankam deshalb
entwickelt die Firma Evolva die auch mit
Kagel zusammenarbeitet ein
fermentationsverfahren den manipulierte
Häfen produzieren stevio Glycoside ohne
beige Geschmack dafür mit umso mehr
geschmeckte Firmen die unabhängig vom
Stevia Anbau sind und Guarani die immer
noch keinen Cent von den Profiten sehen
auch das wird als bio-piraterie
kritisiert und dafür gibt es noch viele
weitere Beispiele robustee Reis oder die
kaplan-pelagonien in natürlichen
erkältungsmedikamenten oft geht
bio-piraterie einher mit einem Bio
Patent aber und das ist vielleicht die
wichtigste Frage dieses Videos hier
können Lebewesen kann genetisches
Material eine Erfindung sein sollte man
leben patentieren können darauf gibt es
keine eindeutige Antwort grundsätzlich
dürfen auch biologische Materialien und
die Verfahren mit denen sie hergestellt
werden patentiert werden in der EU
dürfen aber im Wesentlichen biologische
also konventionelle und Gentechnik freie
Verfahren und Pflanzensorten und
übrigens auch Tierrassen nicht
patentiert werden manche Firmen
versuchen aber das zu umgehen in dem
bestimmte Eigenschaften Verfahren oder
Verwendungsmöglichkeiten unter
Patentschutz gestellt werden der
saatgut-konzern hat im Jahr 2000 zum
Beispiel meist Pflanzen mit einer
bestimmten Konzentration an Öl und
Ölsäure patentieren lassen also eine
Eigenschaft keine bestimmte Sorte unter
das Patent fallen also die speziellen
von gezüchteten Pflanzen aber eben auch
andere natürliche Sorten mit hohem Öl
Gehalt und sogar nicht einmal existente
oder noch nicht einmal entdeckte Sorten
hätte niemand Einspruch eingelegt hätten
Bauern in Peru oder Mexiko
Lizenzgebühren zahlen müssen für den
Anbau von nice den sie schon Ewigkeiten
genutzt haben
durch Biopiraterie verlieren Kleinbauern
und lokale Gemeinschaften also die
Kontrolle über Ressourcen die sie
Teilzeit Jahrhunderten nutzen die Liegen
plötzlich in der Hand von Großkonzernen
nicht so gut geschützt wie Patente sind
meist eure Daten im Netz bei jeder
Aktivität im World Wide Web hinterlasst
die mal kleinere mal größere Datensätze
und auch wenn ihr Datenschutz in den
letzten Jahren deutlich besser geworden
ist und ihr mittlerweile die Möglichkeit
habt die Löschen dieser Daten zu
beantragen so gibt es kaum einen
Menschen der die Zeit hat allen Websites
hinterher zu laufen und selbst dann
wüsste man ja nie wo man anfangen sollte
und wann man wirklich fertig ist und
genau da kommt in kogny ins Spiel
niemand will das persönliche
Informationen für kommerzielle Zwecke
missbraucht werden oder und das ist noch
viel schlimmer in ganz falsche Hände
geraten in KODi hilft euch zu erkennen
wo ihr welche Informationen hinterlassen
hat sei eure Adresse euer Name Fotos von
euch oder gar eure Bankdaten in einem
zweiten Schritt kann inkognittern für
euch Daten löschen Anträge stellen damit
bist du loslegen kann müsst ihr
lediglich eure E-Mail-Adresse angeben
bei mir persönlich wurden direkt 60
Löschanträge gestellt und ich konnte
sehen welche Daten von mir gehandelt
werden und für welche Zwecke sie
weiterverkauft werden wenn ihr auch
wollt dass eure Daten aus dem Netz
verschwinden und sie niemand mehr weiter
verkaufen kann dann schaut mal bei
inkognit vorbei der Link befindet sich
wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung
und mit unserem Code dr Watson bekommt
ihr außerdem 60% Rabatt auf ein
Jahresabo so schützt die nicht nur euch
sondern unterstützt auch noch uns und
unsere Videos und falls ihr noch nicht
zufrieden seid habt ihr natürlich 30
Tage Geld zurück Garantie okay wo waren
wir stehen geblieben ach ja Bio
Piraterie wie lässt sich die denn jetzt
verhindern dafür tritt 2014 das Nagoya
Protokoll in Kraft in dem das sogenannte
access and benefit sharing geregelt wird
das bedeutet der Zugang zu Ressourcen
wird geteilt aber eben auch der nutzen
zum Beispiel in Form von Geld
Technologie oder gemeinsamen Rechten an
den Entwicklungen klingt super aber es
gibt da noch einige Schwierigkeiten
dieses Land kann selbst festlegen welche
Ressourcen wie geschützt werden aber es
kann sehr schwierig sein herauszufinden
wo der Ursprung von Ressourcen oder
Wissen liegt wer genau gehört zu einer
Community einem indigenen Volk oder
Stamm da ist die Eigentumsrechte
bestehen nur für eine gewisse Zeit
verliert auch das traditionelle Wissen
irgendwann diese Exklusivität auf das
alles gibt es keine Antwort sagen auch
die ExpertInnen vom Nagoya Protokoll hat
mit denen wir für dieses Video hier
gesprochen haben es geht ja also weniger
um ein knallhartes Mainz oder deins
sondern eher um Moral und fernes im Fall
der Kapland pädagogonie wurde z.B ein
Teil der Patente fallen lassen und ein
benefit-sharing Abkommen mit den Zusage
geschlossen was aber zwei andere Gruppen
außen vorliest also alles nicht so
einfach noch schwieriger wird es durch
technische Entwicklungen mittlerweile
ist es möglich die digitale Sequenz
Informationen über die DNA auszutauschen
ohne das genetische Material jemals
physisch untersucht zu haben viele
Forscher stellen die gehen Sequenzen
ihres Forschungs Gegenstands online zur
Verfügung andere Wissenschaftler können
dann darauf zugreifen das ist eine coole
Sache weil das kann auch zum Problem für
das ABS werden ein deutsches Institut
untersucht mit abs-abkommen ebolavirus
Varianten anhand der Probe einer
28-jährigen aus Guinea die DSi wird
online veröffentlicht ein
US-amerikanisches Pharmaunternehmen
nutzt die DSi und produziert ein
Medikament gegen Ebola dafür gab es
Millionen an finanzielle Unterstützung
der Regierung aber jetzt hat halt
einfach ein Unternehmen in der Hand ob
und für wie viel Geld Ebola Medikamente
in die Länder gelangen in denen sie
gebraucht werden
okay fassen wir das alles mal zusammen
Unternehmen entwickeln Nahrungsmittel
oder Medikamente und verwenden dabei
wissen von Gemeinschaften dass dort zum
Teil seit Jahrhunderten genutzt wird
erstmal noch kein Problem wenn ihr mich
fragt aus altem Wissen zu lernen ist
keine Straftat und kann uns wirklich
weiterhelfen solange man eine Balance
findet bei der die benefits fair geteilt
werden und niemand auf der Strecke
bleibt aber trotz des nagoya-protokolls
was ja genau das regeln soll gibt es
noch viele offene Fragen zum Beispiel
was die digitale Weitergabe von
Gensequenzen angeht eine super Methode
um Informationen zu teilen und im Fall
von neuen Krankheitserregern schnell
reagieren zu können dort bleibt
vielleicht nicht immer Zeit um ein
herkömmliches ABS auszuhandeln aber
gleichzeitig kann es so passieren dass
ein globales macht Ungleichgewicht an
Wissen Medizin und Geld verstärkt wird
wie man damit am besten umgeht weiß ich
auch nicht natürlich muss weiter an
biologischen Ressourcen geforscht werden
weil sie unverzichtbar für den
Fortschritt der Menschheit sind bis sie
aber tatsächlich bei einem gerechten
access and benefit-sharing angekommen
sind dass das traditionelle Wissen
schützt und schätzt und den Gruppen
gleichzeitig nicht ihre Lebensgrundlage
entzieht bis dahin dauert es wohl noch
schaut euch hier gerne unser Video über
die afrikanische grüne Mauer an was
super super spannend ist und bis dahin
bleibt neugierig